listen queen victoria's here conor the
cat i mean we're talking about two
people who knew how to make an entrance
on their respective seasons what's the
entrance like for you guys interim
paradise
iconic
she said it third uh not quite as iconic
as queen goddess victoria no cat suit
for me this time no cat suit no catsuit
this time it was too hot too sandy on
the beach how did it feel to show up in
like shorts and sandals this time it
felt great i wasn't sweating as much
which was nice
you ditched the crown in a clip i seen
of paradise so what is your title now i
arrive as the goddess
um just new vibes golden but the queen
has been making more appearances
the queen here tonight yeah she's here
well let me bow down to you thank you so
much for gracing us with your presence
today you guys we've waited two years
for bachelors in paradise um how does it
feel to be on uh in mexico and shooting
with everybody
it was really exciting for me and i feel
like we've all like bonded and even
being here i'm like not nervous because
i feel like i'm with all my friends so i
think it's going to be fun for everyone
to watch
all of us have a good time together
connor what was your experience like in
mexico versus katie season of the
bachelorette it was definitely so
different but just like victoria said
one of the most amazing things was
meeting all these people right like
meeting all these new friends and
getting to know people and make some
connections here and there and it was
awesome
you guys got to tell us how much drama
is there how many tears a lot yeah
i i cried you did oh yeah of course i
cried come on
i don't know why i access your friends i
cry i did not cry really i cried and you
didn't wow okay i don't think so let me
ask you this did you kiss any boys while
you're in mexico
you'll have to tune in
connor how about you fess up how many
women did you kiss can neither confirm
nor deny you'll have to wait four days
to find out you can't kiss and tell yeah
exactly
victoria can i ask you what was it like
filming without chris harrison
um it was a new experience well it's
also new to us it was my first time
doing paradise and i thought wells did
an amazing job
and i think that
wells should be the host next year and
i'll be the bartender oh wait that is an
amazing pitch have you talked to abc
warner brothers about this yet i just
thought of it okay
see i wanted to be the bartender we're
gonna have to go bartend i said it here
first
let's see you guys have no chris
harrison this season but there are a lot
of celeb guests what was it like to see
them crash the party it's pretty amazing
to meet david spade
yeah david spade is hilarious and
so funny
he is the voice of the llama in my
favorite film the emperor's new groove
so pretty cool to meet my icon
wow this was a big experience for you
big moment for me absolutely
[Music]
you